[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture une émission pour
mettre en avant les projets culturels
dans les yvelines
au sommaire aujourd'hui une comédie
musicale est en préparation dont les
yvelines une reprise de starmania prévu
au mois de juin un projet culturel mené
par deux artistes yvelinois christophe
et céline le seront avec nous pour nous
présenter leur projet avec la situation
sanitaire actuelle les événements
fleuriste en ligne c'est le cas de bazar
base art
un concert solitaire produisait lutter
contre le cancer il sera disponible en
ligne la présidente de l'association
bazar base à ce nous parlera de
l'événement et puis happy hour c'est un
nouvel album signé stephen guinée
vincent touche à l'alliance d'un
pianiste et d'un batteur composé de 13
titres l'album met en avant les
rencontres et le jazz célia gatson
deviendra un plateau un plateau nous
présenter l'album et je vous le disais
en titre comédie musicale est en
préparation dans les yvelines
il s'agit de starmania basé sur l'opéra
rock de michel berger et luc plamondon
de 1979
à l'origine du projet deux artistes
yvelinois céline et christophe bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes co directeur
artistique sur le projet starmania
qu'est ce qui vous a donné l'idée de
vous lancer dans ce projet bien on est
en fait déjà deux artistes de commandes
moi je m'occupe des cours de danse dans
les yvelines et puis christian aussi une
comédie mais enfin il a un atelier
comédie musicale de son côté et puis le
puits en fait moi starmania samassa a
bercé mon enfance donc du coup c'était
c'était un projet qui me tenait à coeur
et je laisse christophe ce qui vous a
présenté de son côté voit six mois du
coup moi voilà en fait j'ai intégré les
cours que donner céline sur poissy et en
fait c'est réellement trouvé tout l'été
sur le domaine artistique et en fait ça
a été très très vite l'évidence de
de monter un projet ensemble et ex par
manuel maintenant tellement à coeur que
j'ai eu plaisir d'intégrer ce projet
avec vous avez décidé de mener ce projet
ensemble
quelles vont être vos rôles respectifs
j'imagine tête christophe pour vous que
ça va être le champ alors du coup oui
j'ai pris en fait en charge la partie
coaching vocal surtout les chanteurs de
la comédie et donc céline s'occupe
principalement de la chorégraphie du
spectacle et ont fait ensemble la mise
en scène nous
céline vous allez être sur la
chorégraphie c'est ça je vais quand
j'utilise mais mes deux soeurs de les
meilleurs niveaux avancés pour pouvoir
participer au projet et puis du coup je
vais je vais au lieu d'être aussi enfin
d'être simplement la chorégraphe je vais
aussi danser avec mes danseurs dont
partager un moment sur la scène avec eux
voilà et haut niveau au niveau des
répétitions on en est où en ce moment
alors la répétition avec la la situation
actuelle ça vexe et c'est compliqué mais
on arrive quand même à se réuniront en
petit groupe pour pouvoir avancer sur la
mise en scène sur le travail vocal voilà
chez les uns chez les autres surtout
voilà en respectant bien sûr les couvre
feu mais et voilà on essaie de trouver
le moindre créneaux possibles pour
pouvoir avancer pouvoir être prêt en
fait dès qu'on pourra remonter sur scène
j'ai vu vous aviez également créé une
page facebook un compte pour qui un peu
dédié aux projets pour partager cette
aventure
comment ça marche alors c'est une page
en fait qui qui a été mis en place
justement pour pour montrer un peu aux
gens qui viennent voir des spectacles
mais qui savent pas forcément ce qui se
passe
sur toute la préparation donc et comme
ça un projet qu'on a envie de monter sur
une envergure un petit peu semi
professionnel on veut donner la chance
justement aux artistes locaux de
participer à des projets qui sont à
aussi beau que ce qu'on peut voir sur
paris du coup on s'est dit qu'il fallait
qu'on le mette à 2 devant tout le monde
et principalement sur facebook
c'est là on touche le plus de monde et
c'est vrai que on commence à avoir pas
mal de gens qui nous suivait et qui
suivent cette aventure allez-y
non mais c'est ce qu'a dit le christ est
tout à fait juste c'est vrai que
personnellement il ya l'on trouve
beaucoup de grands spectacles sur paris
mais il ya quand même des belles choses
qui se passent dans les îles et moi ça
me tenait à coeur
avec mes élèves de pouvoir leur apporter
ce projet là et pouvoir partager plein
de choses c'est faire du professionnel
avec des amateurs et l'important c'est
de voir évoluer aussi cci sont pas tous
bien sûr un professionnel et du coude et
les voir évoluer au fur à mesure des
répétitions et voir leur leur niveau
avancé que ce soit au niveau des
chanteurs ou des penseurs voilà c'est
génial et c'est une belle aventure
et justement tout cela on parler
d'artistes locaux au niveau du casting
comment ça s'est passé est ce que c'est
un casting 100% hesdinois le 100%
guînois on l'a proposé en tout cas nous
dans nos contacts c'est vrai que nous
n'a la plupart de nos contacts sont dans
les yvelines
mais il était ouvert à tous et je crois
qu'on a on doit avoir un deux chanteurs
qui sont qui sont pas dans les yvelines
à ses proches quand même pas ce qu'il
faut pour être présent pour les
répétitions de lire ils sont pas très
très loin mais la plupart sont quand
même dans les yvelines 95% je dirais
quand même ouais on a eu on a eu des
candidatures qui venaient d'un peu
partout on a eu du candidature qui
étaient venus du sud de la france dans
le nord aussi donc on a touché un peu
voilà différentes régions mais c'est
vrai que l'un des critères c'était de
pouvoir justement créer une cohésion
d'une troupe avec des gens qui seraient
plus facilement disponibles et c'est
vrai que malgré tout au delà des coups
de coeur qu'on a eus artistique voilà on
a préféré aussi créer cette petite
famille de proximité par fait écouter
merci beaucoup christophe francisco et
céline choquée d'avoir été avec nous
marty est je le rappelle du coup c'est
pour un spectacle qui est prévue le 17
juin au théâtre de poissy ils sont co
directeur artistique du projet starmania
et poursuivre le projet rendez vous sur
la page facebook
starmania by céline et christophe ou
même sur le compte instagram starmania
by céline et crise c'est la sixième
édition de bazar base art un festival à
andrésy qui récolte des fonds pour
lutter contre le cancer
cette année avec les mesures sanitaires
le festival proposera un concert en live
stream des concerts et des spectacles
qui seront à 18h30 et à 22h30 sur la
page facebook de bazar base art mais
aussi sur toutes les pages des artistes
interview express avec céline bigot
président de l'association au micro de
céline 400 go bazarbai hazard est une
association qui propose un événement
festif et solidaire tous les ans depuis
2016 on a un fils comme un festival
chaque année au mois de février pour
lutter contre le cancer
[Musique]
il va y avoir des concerts des
interviews sérieuse et puis des
spectacles donc avec la compagnie du
contraire
l'artiste julio do nascimento qui lui à
venir faire les arts durci du cirque de
la danse avec la compagnie the dance
don en ligne sur hello assault on a une
page donc on peut donner directement là
vous tapez lots assaut sur notre site
internet on a un lien directement bazar
bizarre point com et aussi nous avons un
partenariat avec des commerçants de
conflent et de d'andrésy où on a des
boîtes à dons happy hours c'est le nom
du premier album jazz du pianiste
stéphane vinet et son acolyte le batteur
vincent touche à célia garçons gaumont
soir soit vous êtes avec nous sur le
plateau donc c'est un album de jazz dont
le nom n'est pas dû au hasard
nous on essaye les happy hours sont des
rendez vous jazz hebdomadaires qui ont
lieu au prisme à elancourt alors cela
fait cinq ans que stéphane vinet
pianiste et vincent autre char batteur
joue au p au piano-bar hall du théâtre
les deux musiciens ont composé un album
de 13 titres essentiellement jazz et
dont voici un extrait mais revu ce que
vous vivez
la sofico famille
qui profite des 10 12
donc en tout
op
célia c'est un album à beaucoup d'autres
artistes
oui au fil de leurs rencontres les soit
12 lors de leur soirée 1
de nombreux artistes ont collaboré à cet
album alors comme deux contrebassiste
deux saxophonistes un guitariste et
chanteur un chanteur et une chanteuse
on a essayé de construire le répertoire
de ce disque en fonction des morceaux
qu'on a joué et puis en même temps
qu'ils qui reflétait l'ambiance comment
se sont passées les répétitions en
studio une seule répétition en studio
leur a suffi pour les quelques
arrangements affaires et les voilà
partis
comme lors des happy hours écouter un
autre extrait est suivie et des quelques
mots de vincent touchard le batteur dont
mme kosor et sodas et vous phare
d'amazon
walt pauvre chien stups à un bernard
muna
on joue des standards ce sont des
reprises et les standards de jazz c'est
le répertoire traditionnel on porte
plainte composition de 2,2 de grands
compositeurs américains
cet album est sorti le 22 janvier sur le
label jazz family il est également
l'album jazz de la semaine sur la radio
fit merci de l'aga tombeau d'avoir été
avec nous car si elle travaille le
pastel depuis près de dix ans jeanne
mercier est une artiste yvelinoise de 34
ans basé à saint rémy les chevreuse à
l'occasion d'une exposition de ses
tableaux à magny les hameaux et à
travers elle les vitres de certains
bâtiments notamment la mairie et
l'estaminet
elle nous a ouvert les portes de son
atelier regard des aquarelles acryliques
pastels jane remercie a plusieurs cordes
à son arc
ici l'artiste yvelinoise laisse libre
cours à son imagination
elle aime jongler parmi les genres en
dessinant autant les animaux que les
portraits ou encore les paysages dans le
paysage on est plus libre
2 comment dire de ne pas faire les
choses exactement comme il faut bien
symétrique bien alors que quand je fais
des animaux c'est pour trop pour
retrouver un peu de rigueur que que
j'aime bien en fait le plus portrait
l'artiste trouve son inspiration dans
ses photos de voyages prise au cours du
temps elle modifie ensuite ces clichés
au gré de ses envies
j'ai pris en photo il ya une quinzaine
d'années quand j'étais au château de
versailles donc du coup j'ai ressorti
ses petits clins d'oeil l'inspiration
j'ai toujours c'est juste ça dépend des
moments donc si aujourd'hui j'ai envie
de peindre je sais pas il pleure parce
que j'ai vu qu'une photo mh plaisait va
je peux la faire aujourd'hui mais demain
ce sera pas qu'à jade merci n'est pas
tombé dans l'art par hasard elle
découvre qu'elle est atteinte d'une
maladie il y a une dizaine d'années
l'art devient alors un moyen de s'évader
de s'exprimer près j'ai bifurqué dans
l'art en attendant d'être créée fille
après
j'ai fait je sais pas deux ans après
j'ai dû un temps pour la convalescence
est histoire de commun dire de me
sociabiliser j'ai j'ai fait d'atelier en
atelier fait toutes sortes d'activités
j'ai pratiqué un peu tout ça et le
pastel c'est tombé c'est tombé comme ça
une exposition des tableaux d'eugène
merci est en cours à magny les hameaux
avec la crise sanitaire et les mesures
en vigueur l'exposition a été adapté
elle est visible jusqu'au dimanche 7
février au travers des vitres de la
mairie de l'estaminet et du centre
social une exposition avec pour objectif
notamment de donner de l'espoir aux
personnes atteintes de maladies et c'est
la fin de ce numéro du 7-8 culture merci
de nous avoir suivis elle très bonne
soirée à tous et à bientôt sur télé 78
[Musique]